Hugo tu voulais un petit truc dans tes
yeux de ton esprit ouais tiens fais le
vide dans ton esprit c'est facile c'est
ce que je me suis dit c'était assez vite
donc ça va c'est facile de prendre avec
toi je t'ai piqué ta vanne bon c'est pas
grave on va faire un petit extension il
y a une bonne ambiance
[Rires]
ensemble moi j'aime beaucoup le cinéma
et on va essayer de créer un film
ensemble OK dans un premier temps ici je
suis je me suis fait chier sur un petit
carnet j'ai écrit plein de films et
séries différentes d'accord il y a plein
de films et séries différents
Scream the big bentory docteur House Big
Bang Theory moi c'est pas mal Géraldine
tu viens participer ouais avec plaisir
alors très bien alors j'ai juste demandé
de prendre le carnet tu vas mettre dans
cette position et tu mets ton pouce tu
vas l'ouvrir sur une page et tu prends
connaissance du film ou de la série
excuse-moi juste
on est pas en thalasso là
on dirait qu'on est en salon de massage
frère qui veut des pierres chaudes
allez-y
comme ça ouvre
dans un instant de penser à la première
lettre déjà si c'est un film ou une
série dans ta tête film série alors
est-ce que tu as vu ce qui s'est passé
quand j'ai dit Siri elle a fait oui donc
du coup c'est une série absolument voilà
ok très bien pense à la première lettre
[Musique]
la deuxième OK
ben j'y pense très fort OK
[Musique]
ok est-ce que tu peux annoncer à tout le
monde le film la série que tu as choisi
la Casa de papel
[Applaudissements]
faut trouver un nouvel acteur c'est très
simple ce que j'ai fait c'est que j'ai
fait une liste sur mon téléphone plein
d'acteurs non on a fait différemment
j'ai pris des chroniqueurs ou des
invités qui sont venus sur le plateau
donc une liste entre 1 et 99 d'accord et
tu vas me dire un nombre entre 1 et 99
sélections 88 88 est-ce que tu veux
changer non
je veux juste aller taver marquer
toujours mon poste je te laisse cliquer
dessus et regarder ce qui correspond en
1 il y avait cyreneur deux Valérie
Benaim 88 88 88 ah ouais d'accord c'est
bon je peux pas savoir la personne qui a
choisi tu peux enlever la page s'il te
plaît bien sûr c'est bon je voudrais que
le téléphone
c'est bon très bien alors j'ai demandé
de penser à cette personne
peut-être que ce qu'elle dégage
non j'aime bien quand ailleurs donc
dégage
cette personne est tu vois elle est
toujours souriante donc
elle s'occupe des gens
alors ce que moi je vois dans ta tête
c'est dans la tête c'est que c'est
quelqu'un pas très charismatique ah si
quand même ah ok d'accord c'est une star
c'est une star
c'est bizarre ce que
j'ai l'impression j'ai quelqu'un qui est
parti j'ai Mathieu Delormeau non non
des fois ça arrive de se tromper
la connexion n'est pas bonne je sais
mais moi c'est dur de se connecter mon
ex
toi
[Musique]
cinq sept 9 et on va multiplier par
d'autres chiffres
46 46
et on va multiplier tu vas garder pour
toi le chiffre que tu veux multiplier
d'accord et tu fais égale
ok c'est bon le résultat alors je vais
demander de penser au premier chiffre
ouais ok je l'ai
[Musique]
je crois que
le deuxième c'est bon
le troisième
ouais je le reste aussi tu as tout
OK
est-ce que tu peux annoncer à tout le
monde les chiffres sur lesquels tu es
tombé s'il te plaît le 2
le 3
le 7
le 1
et le zéro
[Applaudissements]
une personne une personnalité et je te
dis la connexion n'était pas bonne
est-ce que tu peux annoncer à tout le
monde la personnalité que tu as choisie
bien sûr alors si je suis tombé sur
Evelyne Thomas
tu veux pas changer
c'est mon choix parce que moi je suis
tombé sur Gilles Verdez
[Musique]
parce que en fait c'est marrant c'est
que c'est une personne que tu aimes
beaucoup
mais c'était c'était ton résultat
c'est toi qui a choisi
sur le plateau
la Casa de paddle arrête la Casa de
papel
très fort
c'est bien fait tu peux pas nous faire
un petit truc encore on adore
on peut rester avec toi pendant 8 ans
est-ce que tu veux le vérifier
alors je vais peut-être vous apprendre
quelque chose
on est d'accord déjà c'est pas un DPP et
est-ce que tu sais comment savoir si un
D est truqué non vas-y alors c'est très
simple en fait les faces opposées en 7
donc 6 du coup on a un 3 et 4 7
tu as pris quelque chose tiens je vais
dire quelque chose c'est que tu as
choisi le 5 je vais demander de le
mettre dans ses positions tu peux
montrer la caméra et ensuite tu caches
comme ça je peux pas savoir le chiffre
ok d'accord je vais me retourner
ok je vais demander de penser aux
chiffres et tu as pensé stop dans ta
tête d'accord par rapport au chiffre que
tu as choisi ok 1 2 3 4 5 6 très fort
très fort mais pas c'est pour moi c'est
un deux
c'est un deux
[Applaudissements]
bravo
résister à mort alors
j'essaye en plus c'est vrai la raison
pour montrer que vraiment et les mecs on
sait pas parler avant je voulais pas le
voir avant en plus je vous dis il est
monstrueux c'est incroyable tu vas nous
faire un dernier truc ou c'est bon moi
non on fait ce que tu veux commencer si
vous voulez un autre chose
sinon je peux dire que de la saucisse il
y a six faces
c'est une chanson qu'un copain fait de
la saucisse il y a six faces c'est là ce
qui est amoureux du 6 mais il le voit
jamais de là
dès que c'est un peu intelligent
tu as compris de la saucisse j'ai pas
compris
je vais t'expliquer il y a quelques
temps je suis parti à Londres j'ai pris
une photo d'une horloge tu la connais
très bien très bonne culture générale
et du coup je vais tenter t'influencer
mais tu vois avant d'arnaquer je te
préviens ok j'ai pris une photo d'une
certaine heure donc c'est à dire qu'il y
a une photo de mon téléphone d'une heure
c'est en journée non moi une heure comme
ça en journée celle que tu veux oui 14h
14h pile alors je vais tenter
d'influencer je te l'ai dit je te
conseille de songer après tu fais ce que
tu veux soit tu acceptes soit tu
acceptes pas mais tu décides non je vais
rester sur 14 heures peut-être que je
dis ça pour t'influencer
on reste en 14h
déjà tu connais pas ton mot de passe
donc
ouais
c'est bon
dans la piqûre
mais est-ce qu'il a pas des photos avec
toutes les heures
[Musique]
[Rires]
mais j'ai envie il est 19h22
et moi j'adore ok on va faire un truc
interactif ah merde que même à la maison
on peut on peut le faire donc on est en
direct on le rappelle 19h22 on est en
direct avec Magic Flo mais on va
non choisis quelqu'un un chronique il
faut qu'il ait quelle qualité
précise
me dire oui ou non ça va oui ou non
c'est pas Daniel ça va être long
Gilles Verdez ça va être trop aigu
Jean-Marie il a déjà fait Géraldine
aussi
j'hésite j'ai dit notre Jean-Michel et
Sophie Coste si envie de le faire on va
dire allez Sophie
s'est demandé c'est très simple c'est un
tour à petit budget donc on va imaginer
on prend un paquet de cartes imaginaire
on jette en l'air et là il y a plein de
cartes affichées d'accord donc tu as de
l'AS au 10 là
c'est les faces on va imaginer que j'ai
un briquet et je me déplacer comme ça tu
veux qu'on s'arrête sur les faces ou sur
les cartes à points d'accord tu me dis
sur les on va s'arrêter sur les figures
sur les figures très bien donc il reste
que les faces
et le 6 au 10 pareil du 6 au 10 du 6 au
10 donc les 6 ou 10 il reste 6 5 6 7 8 9
10 d'accord je passe
si 7 8 9 10
très bien maintenant il faut choisir
entre pic cœur bref ou carreau donc tu
as me dire noir ou rouge
donc il reste cœur au pi ou carreau
une seule carte une un seul symbole le
carreau donc on est tombé
alors quand je dis c'est interactif
c'est même à la maison ils peuvent
regarder sur mon Instagram j'ai fait une
prédiction
donc c'est l'eau tiret du bas artiste
Magic Show voilà
il y a un message
et juste là il y a un petit message
[Applaudissements]
au dessus il y a un petit message
ah oui tu choisis tu choisiras vite tu
choisiras
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on adore
et incroyable bravo magique bravo